يفي فلاديمير بوتين
بوعده بالرد على الولايات المتحدة.
اختبار صواريخ قادرة على إطلاق الصواريخ النووية
من غواصة بالقرب من حدود الناتو ،
المتحدث باسم الأمير بوتين أكد أن
موسكو تعتزم زيادة تعزيز
قواتها بعد انسحاب أمريكا من
معاهدة الصواريخ النووية متوسطة المدى مع روسيا واختبار إطلاق
صاروخها الجديد الخاص بها ، لقد سمعت بالتأكيد
تعليمات الرئيس
لقد تم إعطاؤهم بشكل عام أن هناك
نشاطًا مكثفًا للغاية
مؤخرًا للتطوير العسكري
ولإبقاء قواتنا في الحالة المناسبة
في غضون 48 ساعة تقريبًا
، أجرت روسيا سلسلة من
التدريبات العسكرية لطائرات مقاتلة على إطلاق صواريخ جو -
جو  التحليق من شبه جزيرة القرم المحتلة
، يمارس الجيش ما يسمى
بالنشر الخفي لصواريخ إسكندر متوسطة المدى ذات
القدرة النووية في
كالينينغراد وممارسة
الدفاع الصاروخي المضاد للصواريخ الباليستية في
الشرق الأقصى ، كل هذا حيث
أعرب الرئيس ترامب في قمة مجموعة السبع في فرنسا عن
رغبته في دعوة  روسيا إلى الاجتماع المقبل
لمجموعة
الدول الصناعية الكبرى في الولايات المتحدة العام المقبل
الرئاسة الفرنسية  دينت أمانو ويل مكاو ،
ومع ذلك ، يعترف بأنه لم يتم التوصل إلى توافق في الآراء
مع القادة الآخرين بشأن هذه القضية ،
حيث أبدى الرئيس ترامب قلقه بشأن
مشاعر بوتين ، كما تعلمون أنه شخص فخور
بدعوته ، وسأدعوه
بالتأكيد سواء كان سيأتي نفسياً أم لا ،
أعتقد
أن هذا أمر صعب  شيء بالنسبة له ،
لديك G8 الآن إنها g7 وأنت
تدعو الشخص الذي طرده
الرئيس أوباما حقًا ولأنه
تفوق عليه بذكاء ولكن الكرملين لا
يعترف حتى أنه يريد العودة إلى
قمة دبلوماسي فلاديمير بوتين G7
تقريبًا  الاستهزاء بتقدم الرئيس ترامب ،
لا علاقة لنا به
، لم نطلب من أي شخص أي شيء
اكتشفناه عن هذا من
البيانات العامة لبعض الزملاء الغربيين
، لم نطلب أي شيء بشأن هذه
المسألة ولن نذهب إلى الحياة في
هذه الأثناء.  جهود الرئيس ترامب في
الدبلوماسية تسببت في استمرار التصعيد العسكري ،
كما
أعلنت روسيا أنها ستعيد
تسليح القاعدة السوفيتية القديمة قريبًا  ق على البحر الأسود
بصواريخ جديدة فريد بليتجن سي إن إن
موسكو